they're they're a little bit different
we're different they did a great job
both as players and their coaches so
it's it does like I said yesterday it
feels like a while ago and that's why
you play you have a 16-game season and
in Division you get two chances so we'll
just do everything we can to put that
behind us and try to be better
that's Matt Negi talking about the
rematch of the first game of the NFL's
100th season it was Packers it bears
both teams were sluggish on offense it
was that Green Bay defense that did just
enough there was that one drive from the
Packers when it felt like it was all
going haywire and then bang bang bang
bang touchdown that was enough for the
Packers to win that game they get
together at Lambeau Field with a lot
riding on it for Green Bay Green Bay
loses this when they have to worry about
losing the NFC North Bears are back
bears are still alive for a playoff
berth it's going to be cold at Lambeau
Field this one I look I I can see the
Bears winning this one because to me the
Packers even though they're 10 and 3 I
look at their wins it's like who if they
really beaten and who have they beaten
convincingly they screw around with
teams like Washington they screw around
with teams like the Giants and given
where the Bears are right now you screw
around you're gonna lose to them Mike
first of all thank you for for using the
outline of this show to spend ten
minutes on this great is a huge big cat
fan who's been listening to every
program I go on throughout the week and
has heard this stat about 16 times where
I must say it again anyway the Packers I
look through it on Sunday they've played
52 quarters this season 25 of the 52
quarters they have scored 3 points or
less this offense is very up and down it
feels like they will get on a rhythm
they will start the game they have a
nice plan and then they just kind of
disappear in the second half their
fourth quarter scoring I think it's four
and a half points versus seven and a
half points in their first quarter this
is this is why I think the Bears are
gonna be in this game it's going to be a
close game Akeem Hicks coming back gives
this bears defense teeth I know Roke
wants me
being out is a big blow but they've had
some guys who have stepped up quick
Kowski has stepped up West Virginia boy
has stepped up in his absence and I
think if you have watched the Bears all
season long when Hakeem Hicks went out I
think it was against the Raiders in
London the defense loses its edge
because everything kind of builds off of
him where he lets Khalil Mack and
Leonard Floyd get you know we're either
one-on-one coverage or up against guys
who aren't gonna you know do great
against them he does a great job he
takes away the run so Hakeem Hicks being
back for this game and it's not official
but he should be will have a huge impact
on this Bears defense getting back to an
elite level and being able to win this
game and Mitscher Biscay I really do
believe that the confidence that mr.
Biscay had winning that game on
Thanksgiving Day something has clicked
it's been between the ears for him a lot
of this year and something has clicked
he ran the ball really well against the
Cowboys he's had a little extra rest
here I think the Bears keep this close
and I'm I hate to say this
you're gonna replay this Mike I know
you're gonna replay this next week if it
goes against me but this game is gonna
come down to Ken the Bears make their
field goals and if they do they win and
it's going to be cold at Lambeau Field
the temperature kickoff in the high
teens they're giving away free hot
chocolate to help people from getting
you know any type of of negative
consequence from being out there in the
cold no be the a who's with their shirts
off and and look that is not the kind of
weather you want to mess around with
that kind of stuff and I don't know how
much of the hot chocolate is really
gonna help but hey it's a nice gesture
from the Packers for all the folks who
will be there and they will pack Lambeau
Field for that game it is the oldest
rivalry in the NFL it is a historic
rivalry my point last week was I can't
think of many occasions where both teams
were really good this time around both
teams are over 500 late in the season
both teams are still very much alive the
Packers desperately need this game if
they want to stave off the Vikings at
the top of the NFC North because of the
Packers lose this one the north very
well comes down to week 16 Monday Night
Football Packers at the Vikings and then
the Bears will have a chance week 17 so
screw up the Vikings attempt to win the
division when they go to Minnesota so
the bear
spoil the NFC North now for the Packers
and then spoil it later for the Vikings
and the Bears you know statistically
it's it's they're very very much on the
outside looking in you need help from
the Vikings you need help from the from
the Rams they need to lose two out of
the last three games Bears need to run
the table it's stacked against them but
I think what this Bears team is playing
for more than anything right now is
having next year feel like you know it's
something they're building something
still because there was points during
this 2019 season that it felt like
everything was falling apart then Matt
Nagy was maybe losing a little bit of
his you know hold on the locker room
that mr. Biscay was gonna be out of the
league soon but that feels like it's
come back to earth here for the Bears
and it feels like more like 2018 and
2019 and next year needs to have that
kind of rhythm going into it that's my
take from last week where when I said it
I saw you light up I could feel the
intensity when you realized yes there's
hope for 2020 and there is now
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports